So at this point,
you've seen information about sessions
on the movie database website, and
heard about the movie database
authorization flow from Travis himself.
But once we start writing code for this,
things can get a little complicated.
So to get a good idea of
the organization of all of this and
how it will work in the app,
let's look at a flow chart that
describes how a user will log in.
The first thing we'll need to
do is get a request token.
Once we have that we're
going to login with the API and
then we can create a session ID.
Remember for the movie database,
we need a session to make any
requests that write or update data.
Finally, we'll grab the user ID and
we can then move on to the next view.
Now we can see from the arrows that
these steps need to happen in a specific
order and we wouldn't want to move
onto the new step before our current
step is finished.
It's for that reason that, in our code,
we're going to keep these
steps chained together,
meaning we'll move onto the next one
only after our current step completes.
This means checking each time that
we have the value we're expecting
when a step completes, and printing or
displaying an error if we don't.